let me tell you the joke that got me
into this trouble in the first place I
went to the Institute for Advanced Study
in Princeton and I was at a dinner party
and so I told the following sexist joke
this is a sexist joke there are three
men in a bar a doctor a lawyer and a
mathematician by the way I get my I get
my just desserts at the end of this so
don't worry doctor a lawyer and a
mathematician and they are discussing
whether it's better to have a wife or a
lover a mistress a wife or mistress the
doctor says it's much better to have a
wife because you work all day you come
home at the end of the day you want to
have a steady settled family life the
lawyer says no no no no no it's much
better to have a mistress because maybe
for the first 5 10 20 30 years you'd
like to have a steady family life but if
you change your mind it gets incredibly
complicated so it's much much better to
have a mistress and they're going back
and forth they can't agree so they turn
to the mathematician what do you think
the mathematician says it's better to
have a wife and a mistress and the
reason is your wife will be afraid to
ask if he if you're spending time with
your mistress and your mistress will
know that of course you have to spend
some time with your wife which means you
can spend your time doing mathematics so
I'm sitting at the table and this lady
Betsy divine is at the table she's
married to Frank will check at that time
she and Frank were living in Einstein's
house this is the truth I'm not making
this up they were living in Einstein's
house in Princeton then they moved to
MIT and he goes and gets the nobel prize
in physics so anyway
two weeks later she comes around she is
raising money for the Institute for
Advanced Study softball team you
probably haven't heard of them in the
major leagues and she is selling this
mihnea graft handout I open it up what
is this three women are in a bar a
lawyer an engineer and a computer
scientist and they're debating whether
it's better to have a husband or a lover
so i got my come up and so i said there
look you stole my joke she said yeah i
stole your joke so I said you should
have stolen more of my jokes I have a
lot more so we collaborated and that's
how we did this book now I will tell you
a couple more jokes from that book here
is a limerick which I made up myself and
published in this book there once was a
mathematician who preferred an exotic
position twas the joy of his life to
explore with his wife topologically
complex Co ition so an ecologist and
economist and a statistician go on a
deer hunt and they're creeping through
the forest and they're hunting with bow
and arrow and suddenly they see a deer
right straight in front of them and the
ecologist suddenly first takes careful
aim fires and the arrow goes 5 meters to
the left of the deer because ecologists
are leftist then The Economist takes
careful aim and fires and the arrow goes
5 meters to the right of the deer
because the economist's are rightists
the statistician looks at the two arrows
and looks at the deer and jumps up and
down and says we got it we got it
you